i was kidding and now you're making it
serious because you have a bad sense of
humor where you cannot make it clear
when you're joking and now that's my
problem
that's what i i gotta i gotta get out of
here i can't do this
you say you say i'm gonna go wait a
second this guy should be an actor he's
seriously hell yeah all right we're back
self-esteem restart
[Music]
hello buzzfeed i am ali vigiano and i
play leah in the end of us
and i am ben coleman and i play nick act
like you don't even care about me half
the time i don't think you want to get
back together i think you're just too
lazy to move out and go start your own
life we're here at buzzfeed today where
we both used to work to review some of
our most iconic
fights in videos
and there were many of them this was
actually the first video we did together
when guys think you're obsessed with
them no i'm actually really glad you
brought it up so we're on the same page
about it because i don't want anything
serious but you want a date and we'd
rented an airbnb and i sort of had this
idea for this video i came up with the
concept and we were put on the same like
pod the same team to work to collaborate
the goal of it was to shoot as many
videos as we could in this airbnb
there's no excuse for the hair that i
had my hair looks red no i think it's
probably just the lighting that's
probably what my hair looks like a weird
color too
no that was just the way your hair
looked people didn't get that this was a
joke and i was playing a character
they're like i hate that guy wait a
second this guy should be an actor he's
seriously hell yeah all right we're back
self-esteem restored could i pull off a
mustache i think you could to be honest
why would i ever do that you're just
using your stash to piss me off because
you think it's funny i don't know what
you're talking about okay well what if i
stop shaving oh no there's food in the
mustache now and it's gross i've still i
support my reaction that's a great
reaction thank you oh my god my stash
bro yeah your stash bro he shaved his
stash wow it's crazy how far we've come
ali i know so yeah i feel like this is
like early stages of the fighting but
let's watch the next video and see if it
escalates let's let's uh on again off
again couple why do you even have dvds
ben it's a collection this video is
insane
and it was so fun to make we could not
stop breaking we were laughing so much
it reminds me of when we were shooting
the movie we were able to kind of improv
around like this and there was a lot of
breaking as well it was like all right
here's a scene and just start fighting
and let's go to a new scene and fight
fight we fought so much in this video so
do you feel like fighting is an
important part of a relationship i used
to feel like fighting was like
passionate and it's like how you showed
that you like cared about something and
now i'm like let's talk about this issue
you know what i mean now have you ever
done this in a fight
yeah there there are some new forms of
fighting that are not featured in any
buzzfeed videos in the end of us so
definitely check it out in theaters on
december 3rd
[Music]
you